foreign
[Music]
I'm a product manager at Google and I
focus on identity specifically Workforce
with any Federation which this
presentation is about and um luckily or
thrilled to be joined by Ellen from
VMware today Ellen how you doing doing
pretty good Stephen happy to be here and
um as Stephen just said my name is Alan
Gamboa I'm currently a full stack
engineer at VMware
great Ellen thanks very much for joining
me today uh Ellen's uh it's a great day
event in terms of making this uh real in
terms of customer actually leveraging
the capability of this of this feature
so just in terms of what we'll be going
through
um as I mentioned Workforce identity
Federation is a new offering that
extends uh Google's existing Cloud
identity management capabilities and it
lets you use your uh your existing
identity provider and I say existing
potentially some third party basically
an external to Google identity provider
and you want to utilize those user
identities to authenticate and authorize
access to Google resources and that's
what workflows with the information
about so we'll be going through that
I'll give you an overview and then I'll
be handing over to Ellen in terms of
detailing their specific scenario and
Ellen's currently also got a demo for us
and sort of a game showing this this
capability in action so let's jump
straight in in terms of this product so
very simply in terms of you know what is
the current reality customers are
experiencing today
uh when it comes to identity management
things are getting more complex the
security risk is getting bigger and
they've got to consider what the user's
experience is making sure it's seamless
the store your adequate controls and
making sure customers can users can get
access to the things they need to get
their jobs done
um so that onboarding and protecting
users obviously imperative
um seamless experience I mentioned so
it's things like single sign-on users
don't want to have to remember multiple
usernames and passwords they want to be
able to leverage you know that rich
capability they have for the
organization that's just a multi-factor
authentication and leverage that same
identity in terms of accessing other
systems so single sign-on is imperative
is privacy and Regulatory considerations
to consider and then when I talk about
that seamless or that management again
just like users don't remember multiple
username and passwords the organization
also wants to try and simplify the the
management of those RDP Solutions so
especially when we start considering you
know multi-cloud environments now as
well so all these considerations are key
and this is you know these are the
couple of things things that Workforce
with any Federation delivers on so let's
explain how it does that so very simply
uh you can read you're going to solve
from the on the left there but what we
have with with work with identity
Federation is an ability to quickly
enable users leveraging those existing
identity providers user and entities or
stores right there and give them direct
secure access to Google cloud services
and resources
um so the big Point here is they do not
you don't need to synchronize Workforce
user identities now consideration or
previously with Cloud identity is you
know we could obviously always Federate
um but the reality is you then have to
synchronize those active directory or
after or forger operative Mr B you need
to synchronize those identities into
Cloud identity and that's again as I
mentioned additional management overhead
so with this new capability it is a
singular synchless experience very
simply the user will log in to the
existing identity provider and they will
get issued a token and that token is
then passed through to Google and it is
checked basically there's attributes in
that token checking things like group
membership for example the user's name
whatever it might be whatever you want
to contain within it within that token
and then conditional access is given
based on those attributes an example is
something like a group if you want to
give access to you know permanent
employees versus temporary employees as
long as that token stipulates uh that
member or that user is a member of the
respective group then they're given or
denied access so it gives you that that
granularity and Workforce identiferation
is Broad in terms of you know the the
services that you can leverage our
detail on our product page which I'll
share at the end of the presentation but
very simply in terms of once they
authenticate and I'll show you in a
second as I said the architecture here
but they're giving access they can
access via the cloud console they can
Leverage The SDK Renault is like the
Google Cloud CLI or an API a bigquery
API or you know gke API for example
whatever the service is that that user
requires they can access it on interface
via this by this mechanism them as long
as obviously it's one of the Google
supported products that was one of the
products that supports Workforce
identity Federation
so when I think of why customers would
want this I detail some of the pains
they're experiencing today but in terms
of these four key things I've identified
or that the team has identified at the
moment uh in terms of what we see
um sinclus I just detail is imperative
in terms of making sure this isn't
another thank you store that has to be
managed then in terms of if we look at
control
anytime we look at identity and security
you know fine-grained access controls
imperative again and it's through
attribute mapping and attribute
conditions that we can enable that with
Workforce vending Federation and then
sort of flexibility versus Workforce and
inflation is currently supports open ID
connect standards and therefore sorry
big point it supports all the open ID
connect or seml2 protocols so therefore
any external IDP that supports those
those protocols can be leveraged with
this with this capability and then in
terms of looking at from a sovereignty
perspective
uh you know we've got to consider in
terms of where data is stored and
identity is one of those considerations
so for organizations you need it from an
industry editing perspective or a
country sovereignty perspective a
capability like this will allow them to
take where that where those entities are
stored and therefore not within Google
for this specific example so where that
is applicable it'll be another advantage
of leveraging a technology like this
and then in terms of I did mention just
showing a more of an architecture
diagram so let's just look at the flow
that would be followed here so as I
mentioned the user in this case a
developer logs on to the existing
third-party IDP they will then obviously
authenticate whatever mechanisms or
conditions have been dictated via their
IDP once they are successfully
authenticated they get given a token
that token is sent through to Google via
the security token service and security
token service first as an evaluation it
refers to something called the workforce
identity pool and the workforcement pro
is that is the basically the container
of their configuration of relationship
between the third party identity
provider and Workforce identity
Federation so it contains the the the
conditions uh what attribute mappings
there are all those things I've detailed
earlier in terms of the configuration
mapped to IIM policies to allow the line
all those got contained within their
identity pool so the SES service will
evaluate the specific request against
that Paul see if it's Reddit is a
particular particular attribute mapping
and involved that is uh correct it will
then send back a token to that specific
user and that user will be redirected to
the relevant service in this case as you
can see as to the gcp console and
they'll then have the right permissions
to access the relevant resources
again detail too specifically what the
IM policy allowed not broadly but
obviously still giving as I mentioned
that fine grain access control so
obviously you can see the full flow here
is very beneficial in terms of taking a
varieties of the of the user's common
experience of signing in for example so
that's obviously beneficial now one
thing I don't think I did mention was
that Workforce identity people identity
pool is configured but available in a
specific project but is available in a
gcp product that is but is available
organizational wide so a second project
third project whatever might be is also
able to leverage this identity pool for
this authentication but the reverse is
you could also have multiple IDP
configurations in one identity pool so
if you wanted to support you know
multiple you know Ping Identity Forge
rock and all these within that single
pool to your wide spectrum of before
users but to the same resources you can
allow you could configure that way as
well so there's a lot of granularity in
terms of what you could do here
um as I mentioned Ellen's on the cause
are introduced himself and uh what I
think is more beneficial is that you can
see some of this stuff in action so I've
asked Ellen to come today and present in
terms of what the VMware scenario was
and then as I said he's going to follow
up with a fantastic demo so Ellen thanks
again and over to you
thanks Stephen
uh so over here at VMware we have a
thousands of employees and a thousands
and hundreds of teams all or many of
them leveraging uh cloud computing
Solutions across you know all the
providers including gcp as you can
imagine uh trying to manage all these
different projects and Accounts at scale
can be quite a nightmare especially from
a security perspective the last thing we
want to do is have each individual
employee create and and manage an IM
user for themselves right so in order to
do this at scale internally we developed
a product called cloud gate uh which uh
which handles all of this all of this
for for our various employees given the
prevalence of gcp within our
organization we need a solution that
would allow us to do this at scale for
DCP as well so this is where um you know
Workforce pools come in for the rescue
and I plan to demonstrate this with the
following demo this is our product cloud
gate right which allows us to uh
you know manage access at scale to have
to create IM users respond temporary
credentials of of service accounts right
that are appropriately scoped with the
right permissions right
so as an example let me go to the our
common organization and um
game uh temporary access to one of the
accounts here
so I can get both uh programmatic access
at the appropriate level right as a
member of my specific team that manages
this product I have up to admin but
others may only have you know read only
for for instance right when you click
programmatic access
we can get uh these specific environment
variables which we can just paste
into the terminal
right as you can see access to secret
access key whatnot and uh from there we
can
run commands uh additionally we can also
get
uh web access right
all right so this is what we're trying
to recreate with gcp
uh so gcp uh what they offer is
Workforce pools
to use the workforce schools right yeah
a little bit of setup is required right
you have to define a billing project
once you define a building project you
can create a
a Workforce pool by you know providing a
Workforce full name uh and in the
organization that that Workforce pool is
going to belong to right
um
and then once that's created right
you can then attach an identity provider
to that Workforce pool
and you have to give it some some
information that's required
most and most importantly being the the
client ID which you can actually get
from the
identity token that uh
your identity provider exposes so it
would be the odd claim here for instance
then also very important is this mapping
of
uh I think this is actually a better
example here this mapping of uh I guess
uh claims or attributes in your token to
uh claims or attributes that gcp
understands right
right so here uh we said that the gcp
role claim in our
identity token
here
should be mapped to the
uh role claim that the Google SCS
understands
and this is this is key because this is
how we we um can you know Define
principles in gcp uh that will be
appropriately uh scoped and with the
appropriate permissions you know to do
the things that we need to do right
so on that note I can actually show you
uh a principle that I have already
defined
um you know in our internal uh gcp
organization here
and this is the this is what it looks
like right it follows this convention
where you know you define principal sets
uh blah blah blah blah blah the name of
the workforce pool that's going to be in
use right and as you can see here
attribute role right this is this is uh
we do the I mean it's a role-based uh
permissions uh
and then this term is what's important
this term matches
power user here for instance right so
anyone who provides uh an identity token
like this
with gcp role attributes
um
will have the SES will recognize this
and and understand that you know
anything any principle with power user
on the end here
um that
the the access tokens provided will have
the the permissions attached with that
principle right in this case it's
browser and service usage admin
all right uh so I've already set this
all up my Workforce pool is in place
um I can go ahead and just do the uh
we get the identity token and do the
exchange right so let me demonstrate
the the scripts that I've written to do
so
um
this one here just makes a request to
the identity provider that we have in
our in my development environment to get
an identity token with this additional
plane
so I'm just going to run that
I'll have an identity token right
um
this other script
has a method
that makes a call
to the Google SDS
token endpoint
takes the identity token that I just
demonstrated
and gives me back the access token
that will allow me to do the things I
need to do in gcp
um you know this is all documented in
your internal docs you know what it
needs what this endpoint needs you know
um and uh but these are these are the
main things you know provided the
identity token you know the project
number
and whatnot
so let me run this script
and provide it the identity token that I
just generated using
our internal identity provider which has
the the gcp role attribute already
attached
and there I have and we can see that uh
the G the Google SDS provided me with an
access token that I can now use to do
the things I need to do
so let me see uh let's first make sure
that we're not authenticated here on
this terminal
it's a gcp
as you can see I don't have any uh any
permissions here to do anything
and that can be further illustrated by
trying to run this command
oh wait
this worked because I already had uh the
environment variables
wait
sorry about that so let me unset this
all right
and I get the error right
equal to the new axis token that we were
just provided by gcp
hit enter and we exported that variable
now if we try to list projects
you see that we can
that's it folks over to you Stephen
thanks very much Ellen I hope you got
value from that demo as much as I did uh
first of all I just want to say please
go and have a look at the this URL
that's on your screen at the moment uh
if you want to get more information on
the capabilities of this product and
reach out to your your Google contact uh
if you would like to try that Ellen I
just want to thank you very much
obviously these sessions are always much
more powerful when we have the
customer's voice so I really appreciate
uh you you've been participating today
and the valuable the value that you gave
us and um everybody else I hope you have
a great uh next 22.
[Music]